PEOPLE WHO DID IT THE MOST
OF ALL.
WE’RE JOINED NOW BY
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES OF
CALIFORNIA.
GREAT TO SEE YOU,
CONGRESSMAN.
SO,.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
>> Tucker: WE GOT AN
INDICATION FROM SENATOR
LAMAR ALEXANDER OF TENNESSEE
LATE THAT WE’RE NOT GOING TO
GET WITNESSES IN THE SENATE
PORTION OF THIS PROCEEDING
AND BASICALLY THERE IS
NOTHING LEFT.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A VOTE
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO BE
ACQUITTED.
WHY IS IT CONTINUING
EXACTLY.
DO YOU KNOW?
>> WELL, THEY HAVE TO
ACTUALLY GET TO THE POINT OF
WHERE THEY ACTUALLY VOTE TO
ACQUIT, WHICH I GUESS IS
GOING TO OCCUR ON WEDNESDAY.
SO THEY HAD TO VOTE ON THE
RULES FOR THAT BUT I
ACTUALLY HAVE SOME BAD NEWS
FOR YOU TONIGHT, TUCKER ON
FRIDAY NIGHT.
I KNOW YOU DON’T WANT THE
BAD NEWS.
BUT THE PRESIDENT IS GOING
TO BE ACQUITTED BUT THE
PROBLEM IS THIS ISN’T GOING
TO END.
LIKE I JUST CAN’T IMAGINE
THAT ADAM SCHIFF, AFTER
THREE AND A HALF YEARS OF
THIS NONSENSE AND JERRY
NADLER ARE NOT GOING TO
CONTINUE THIS.
RIGHT?
THEY ARE GOING TO GO BACK
AND SUBPOENA JOHN BOLTON.
WE’RE GOING TO HAVE THE SAME
EXACT THING THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN SEEING FOR THE LAST
THREE AND A HALF YEARS.
I JUST THINK YOU SHOULD
PREPARE.
WE THOUGHT ONCE MUELLER
COLLAPSED COMPLETELY.
WE THOUGHT OKAY, WE’RE GOING
TO GET ON TO BUSINESS.
AND THEN OUT OF NOWHERE THIS
UKRAINE HOAX APPEARED.
AND, LOOK, THIS REALLY IS A
HOAX.
THIS WAS ADAM SCHIFF AND HIS
STAFF CONCOCTING THIS ALL
TOGETHER WITH PEOPLE WHO
KNOW EACH OTHER.
ALL THESE PEOPLE KNOW EACH
OTHER THAT CONCOCTED THIS
STUPID UKRAINE HOAX THAT WE
HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH IN
THE LAST WEEK IN THE
ASTRONAUT.
BAD NEWS FOR YOU TONIGHT.
I BET EVEN AFTER THE
ACQUITTAL WE WILL BE WORKING
ON THIS.
>> Tucker: SINCE YOU ARE AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL AND KNOW A
LOT ABOUT POLICY BUT ALSO
POLITICS IS THERE ANY
EVIDENCE THAT THIS WORKS?
MY CANDIDATES WHO WIN ARE
THE ONES WHO SPEAK ABOUT
ISSUES PEOPLE CARE ABOUT.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT THIS.
WHY ARE DEMOCRATS CONTINUING
TO DO THIS?
>> I DESCRIBED IT EARLIER
THIS WEEK AS THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS LIKE THE DOG THAT
CAUGHT THE CAR THEY HAVE
BEEN PROMISING ALL THIS
CRAZY STUFF AND NOW THEY ARE
GOING TO GET SOMEBODY WHO IS
NOT EVEN A DEMOCRAT BERNIE
SANDERS AS THEIR NOMINEE.
A MONTH AGO I WOULD SAY
BERNIE IS GOING TO GET
SECOND OR THIRD PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO WIN.
IS HE WINNING IN EVERY STATE
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS THE BIG PRIZE WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY A MONTH AWAY.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> HE IS WINNING IN IOWA.
THIS COULD BE -- IF BERNIE
WINS ON MONDAY NIGHT, YOU
HAVE AN ENTIRE TAKEOVER BY
THE EXTREME LEFT OF THE
HISTORIC DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT NO LONGER CEASES TO EXIST
IT WILL BE THE SOCIALIST
PARTY.
>> Tucker: A REPLAY OF WHAT
HAPPENED WITH DONALD TRUMP
AND THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THE ESTABLISHMENT HATED HIM.
TRIED RECOGNITION THE SYSTEM
TO PREVENT HIM FROM BECOMING
THE NOMINEE ANT IT DENIED
WORK.
DEMOCRATS ARE TALKING ABOUT
TAMPERING WITH DELEGATES AT
THE CONVENTION NOW.
WILL THAT WORK?
>> THERE IS A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN TRUMP AND BERNIE
SANDERS.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE THERE
IS.
>> AND I MEAN JUST IN THE
POLITICS OF THIS.
BERNIE SANDERS IS A
SOCIALIST.
I MEAN, THE GUY SPENT HIS
HONEYMOON IN THE SOVIET
UNION.
DONALD TRUMP HAD -- YOU
KNOW, HE HAD HIS OWN BRAND
OF POLITICS THAT CAUGHT
EVERYBODY OFF GUARD BUT HE
DOES BELIEVE IN A FEW
IMPORTANT THINGS.
HE WAS VERY CLEAR HE WAS
AGAINST THE IRAQ WAR FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING.
HE WANTS TO BRING THE TROOPS
HOME AS MUCH AS HE CAN HE
ALSO WANTED TO REDO TRADE
DEALS.
ALL THINGS THAT PEOPLE,
INCLUDING MYSELF, WERE VERY
SKEPTICAL IF HE COULD
ACTUALLY DELIVER ON SOME OF
THIS.
DESPITE ALL THE CRAZINESS
AND FOR THREE AND A HALF
YEARS REALLY SINCE THE END
OF 2015 DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
CAMPAIGN BEING UNDER
INVESTIGATION BY THE FEDS,
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN, THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE.
DESPITE ALL OF THAT, THE GUY
IS DEFYING THE ODDS.
I WOULD HAVE NEVER THOUGHT
THAT WE COULD HAVE NOT ONLY
REWROTE NAFTA, BUT ACTUALLY
PASSED IT.
IT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
POPULAR TRADE AGREEMENTS
EVER PASSED IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES A AND THE
SENATE.
IT’S AMAZING WHAT HE HAS
ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISHING QUITE ACC
DESPITE EVERYTHING.
>> Tucker: YEAH AND IN THE